many millennials are still struggling
financially one
generation which is one percent controls
more wealth
for ruining this financial crisis
thank you for agreeing to talk with me
you will have the opportunity
to tell your story
can you give that to me
i got a nice job it's just a startup and
i think you'd be perfect for it
what's the business
[Music]
throw this on before you get out
they would steal anything of value and
then just destroy the rest for fun
and mel donnelly is how they made money
you had someone without asking me and
bring them to my place of business
i didn't see anything oh yeah you did
you say one word to anyone i dare you
everybody knows very few people have all
the wealth and they like to keep it that
way
we're not just stealing we're sending a
message
if someone considers going off the
tracks my face will be the last thing
all of you see you have not been honest
with me
you made the choice to make it harder
for yourselves
you don't think i have a plan you're not
here to hurt anybody right i mean that
just went
great
[Music]
this is the end what did you do
we rather be dead than submit to the
[Music]
system
you